from the post millennial fox fox loses
one billion dollars after parting ways
to Tucker Carlson the fox Corporation
stock plummeted as much as five percent
on Monday wiping out 930 million dollars
in market value following the
announcement that Fox News has parted
ways with Tucker Carlson according to
Business Insider shares the media
company recovered slightly after so it
dropped it ended up at like 29 the
decision to part ways with Carlson
announced less than a week after the fox
Corporation Dominion voting blah blah
blah Carlson was one of the Network's
most popular hosts blah blah blah you
know I saw some really interesting
commentary from Glenn Greenwald you
wanna know what he said how come the
left doesn't care about Hannity
how come the left doesn't complain about
Hannity or Laura Ingram
and they he said it's because Tucker's
the only one who was anti-war and
anti-big Pharma yeah so the left went
after him and completely ignores the
safe GOP
and that's what Fox News wants to be
they don't want Tucker Carlson coming
out here and saying these things yeah
they want someone to go on and just be
like big corporations are great
everybody just do what the government
says exactly they would love that a
Tucker one honors like the left wants
you to think that these corporations
doing bad things to America they're our
best friends actually they do great
things
thank you
um but I sort of mentioned this
yesterday that CNN is the network that
tells you what you're supposed to
believe and then Fox is the network that
tells you what you're allowed to believe
so if you don't want to buy into what
CNN is saying they'll push you over to
Fox and that's still within the realm of
acceptable opinion but Tucker's a little
Bridge Too Far yeah he's a bridge a
little too far it's too far man yeah
yeah then he actually says something you
know cable news commentators they're all
buzzwords apparently now they got the
launch this thing on his website where
it's like you can text some number to
like Tucker to 4-4 or something or
whatever and then they'll send you
information on what he's planning to do
or something like that oh really yeah
it's like you'll get it you'll get
notified when he announces his next big
move or whatever I think Tucker
Carlson's gonna end up making 100
million bucks a year off this
termination Fox if Fox was paying him I
think they say like if you Google it
says his salary is 35 million imagine
how much Fox needs to make off of his
show in order to pay him 35 million
dollars a year and run Fox yeah yeah
that's kind of crazy though I mean
I don't I don't understand how they pay
I think what Hannity gets like 60
million or some other ridiculous number
Hannity was getting paid more than
Tucker Oh yeah
it does have seniority but I imagine
Tucker's a much bigger but that wasn't
bringing in a lot of advertising money
because ah that makes sense they all
boycotted him yes well according to the
same website handy was getting the
comparable salary hmm
good yeah he was getting 34 million plus
a 5 million bonus I don't I I don't
think he should make more than Tucker
are you kidding me absolutely not yeah
but I don't trust these websites
celebrity net worth as a salary is 45
million I read somewhere that he was
getting 60 million this one says he gets
25 million these websites are all fake
other people doing these like End Zone
dances about Tucker being fired from Fox
like didn't we just go through this a
couple years ago when Barry Weiss would
left the New York Times and the same
people were doing the same End Zone
dances and then she went on to create
the Free Press which is like dwarfs any
oh it's probably so rich now absolutely
I mean I think she already comes from
like a well-life family and now the rich
have gotten richer because the New York
Times decided to unleash her yeah
exactly so imagine Tucker Carlson he's
gonna like 10x that right you got to
make a video you got to make a cartoon
about like Tucker Scrooge McDuck
swimming and he's getting a bunch of
money look I hope that's what happens I
appreciate the optimism I'm seeing from
a lot of conservatives on this part of
my concern is you know voiced this
yesterday is that because Fox tells
people what is acceptable it was great
to have Tucker there to help shift that
Overton window and introduce a new
audience to ideas that the rest of us
are familiar with or have been reading
up about online but that that audience
wouldn't give credibility to seeing it
on the internet as opposed to cable
television I certainly have no doubt
that Tucker Carlson is going to be
extremely successful it's going to be
fine it's a question of is his message
going to spread as far and wide I hope
so I'm not saying it won't I'm just
saying that having that platform was
definitely very good for America having
someone on cable television saying the
things Tucker was saying was very good
for America I think they also had to pay
out his contract
meaning if he was getting like they
can't just sever his contract so I
imagine they went to him and said we're
terminating your show and he was like
then you owe me 30 million dollars for
the rest of the year and they went okay
and had cut them mature apparently they
they he found out 10 minutes before they
made the announcement so they had to
have just paid him right because you
unless they unless they're like this
this is the crazy thing about these
contracts with these big with these big
networks is they they give themselves
like morality Clauses to terminate you
in violation of what the contract is
supposed to do it's like hey we're gonna
hire for three years we're gonna pay you
x amount of dollars for three years then
buried in it says we can fire you for
this specific reason then they just wait
until they can justify whatever that
reason is and then you're gone and they
don't pay you for it but I imagine
they're paying Tucker
I imagine they just wrote a big fat
eight-figure paycheck Tucker girls and
uh he doesn't have to work what's he
gonna do he's also it's Tucker Carlson
like the heir to like the the oh Henry
candy bar fortune or something he he
married into the TV dinner
Fortune oh he's he's in so his wife is
the air heiress to Swanson TV dinners
something like that yeah the Henry thing
that was a Seinfeld reference wow yeah
did he have but you're not old enough to
understand the sign Force only 90s kids
remember that's right is that what
you're talking about some kind of
prominent family himself I'm not sure I
don't know uh yeah the the Vanderbilts
oh wait that's Anderson Cooper oh
and then he got a summer internship at
the CIA which he abruptly left and then
went to uh I think Iraq to report on the
Iraq War and then got a job working for
the uh for CNN Anderson Cooper had a CIA
I think a two-year I think it was for
two years summer internship
do you ever leave the CIA no you don't
all right well there you go I was
hanging out with Luke radkowski once and
we were in I think we were in Atlanta or
something and then he saw Anderson
Cooper and he ran up and he was like
Anderson Anderson
you work for the CIA and then I was like
Luke how would I you like what are you
doing like what does that accomplish and
Anderson was just like what are you
talking about and like walked off
because the saying is once CIA always
CIA you know yeah I mean I think the way
it works is that you're not you might
not be on the payroll but you're an
asset right there's like there's
informal relationships you might not
even realize you're an asset but you've
got relationships they cultivate
relationships in you then you know they
maintain those relationships well I want
to ask the audience here we have this
other story from post millennial
subscribers ditch Fox Nation or guitar
girls Tucker Carlson leaves Network
quote just canceled my Fox Nation
subscription no point in having it
without Tucker Carlson Originals is
anybody who watches this show subscribed
to Fox Nation I did see comments in the
or I saw people chatting and like I
canceled my Fox Nation subscription so
there was some overlap
yeah maybe not anymore maybe they'll I
don't know I'm just kind of thinking
like why is all this happening at once
ABC News fire eight the Disney fired
Nate silver uh BuzzFeed news shut down
yeah Don lemon's fired Tucker Carlson's
out it's there's like some coordinated
things is a global conspiracy are they
trying to turn the frogs gay or
something probably yeah that's got to be
behind it at some point I mean I don't
exactly know how it twists and turns to
get us to that point but I think that's
a safe bet
I mean isn't this just kind of a
reckoning like like these I mean both
the Legacy Media and these New upstart
Media Outlets that came out around like
2013 or so you know your vices and your
buzzfeeds and stuff I mean the Legacy
Media has been on the deathbed for a
long time and those new those new Jack
ones have too I mean they've been like
maybe they had a little bit of lead time
over the over the cable news channels
but like I mean Does anybody read
BuzzFeed news like does anything yes I
swear I get all of my information
BuzzFeed news you spoke with somebody
earlier today who expressed some
concerns of well they know a lot of
people like within the Republican
establishment who are sort of expressing
some some concerns over whether or not
the audience that Tucker had on on Fox
is actually going to follow him to a
smaller Network or an independent
Network or any of his next project so
maybe they're just sort of trying to
take him off the board again ahead of
the 2024 election he's too big of a
figure to cancel completely but the
thinking is that some of the people who
watched him on Fox May not follow him to
any other platform and get the
information that he was putting out
that's my yeah that's my my fear and
that's basically what I was saying you
know basically I think the basic
conversation is that um Brian Kilmeade
is going to be a much more based a
version of hooker Carlson you know
everyone thinks Brian Kilmeade is uh is
the new Tucker yeah that's what I keep
hearing the kids say on twitter.com it's
actually I I guess it doesn't work it's
not funny because no one knows who Brian
Kilmeade is but right yeah he's not
talking about Jesse Waters was the
number two show right yeah I mean why
don't they put Jesse in that slot yeah
yeah does anybody have a reason I don't
know I couldn't tell you why they should
or shouldn't they should uh just not put
anyone in that slot and just put dead
air exactly it just and now a moment of
silence for the next hour for the next
hour and in memory of Tucker Carlson and
then it just shows black and white
pictures of him with sad piano music
playing like Tucker Carlson year of
birth to 2023 so that that's what
they're gonna do to convince the
audience like that he's dead don't
follow him anywhere
we never said he was dead you can't take
us to court but they just mislead the
audience into thinking he's dead so that
they can effectively cancel them so I
guess the we have this video from
ocasio-cortez I'll play for you I'm
sorry that I have to do this to you but
we'll play it anyway
is there no sound out at Fox News here
we go Tucker Carlson is out at Fox News
couldn't have happened to a better guy
um
what I will say though is
while I'm very glad that the person that
is arguably responsible for the
some of the largest driving some of the
most amounts of death threats and
violent threats not just to my office
but to plenty of people across the
country
um I also kind of feel like
I'm like waiting for the cut scene at
the end of a Marvel movie after all the
credits have rolled wow and then you see
like the villains like hand oh my gosh
re-emerge out to glip grip over like the
end of a building or something
but
deep platforming Works no it is
important remember when Captain America
D platform the red school
just like Marvel you guys it's like the
Avengers
a giant corrupt corporation fired him
for speaking out against corporations
and corporate goodness
superheroes bro oh my goodness what I
found fascinating about this is that
she's celebrating an anti-war
personality yes being removed from a
major corporate Network
and she doesn't care at all about
Hannity or Laura Ingram or any other
other personalities that's something
you'd think she'd be able to see okay
Tucker does have right wing politics and
that's bad and scary but you know what
everyone else on Fox does as well and
Tucker is also anti-war and he speaks
out against corporate greed but she is
on the side of a lot of the corporations
that he speaks out against so it's not
convenient and I don't really think
she's all that Dr Carlson who are we
dealing with here had that famous moment
where he was doing the handoff with
Hannity and he was complaining about
Amazon exploiting its workers or
something like yes and him and Hannity
argued he's like well some people like
the free market Tucker he's like oh no
but I'm saying and he talks more like
this some people want a good product
from Amazon they're allowed to buy it
and Tucker goes
excuse me idiot says what he's like what
and he's like he just said he's an idiot
you heard it America and then he goes
Tucker you said what in order to say
that I was saying what and then Tucker
was like oops it's default and then
that's that's a Tucker like it was like
skirted out but in all seriousness so I
think that was a moment where I was
fairly obvious
Tucker was Tucker was getting the views
and they liked it but he was at odds
with their with the GOP machine I wonder
if this play is more so because they
want to get away from Trump and away
from Maga um like people were saying
it's clearly about the Dominion lawsuit
it's like well Hannity and other
personalities we're talking a lot about
the same thing too and Tucker actually
was rejecting the the the 2020 narrative
from Trump yeah and he got attacked for
it by by uh Trump supporters that's what
I'm so confused about like like if it
was about the if it was about the
election and
why would they not have gotten rid of
Maria Bartiromo and yeah she was way
more into that yeah could he just be the
first Domino
um I mean it would be Domino I gotta be
honest it would be like the coolest
thing ever if like within the next two
weeks every single Fox personality is
fired except Sean Hannity he's the only
guy there all 24 hours
he's not sleepy anymore now he knows how
the Amazon workers feel He's just never
sleeping and he's like maybe there
should be labor laws or something I
don't know it's crazy yeah maybe I need
a union or something today's 24-hour
cycle is brought to you by modafinil do
you guys know I'm a definite no it's
what uh snipers and astronauts take it's
a pill that makes you know kind of sleep
oh my gosh yeah I took it for it's like
a narcolepsy drug in the 60s in France I
took that out from a ranger actually
yeah yeah and uh I think the brand name
is pro vigil or something and apparently
you don't got to sleep if you take it
how many times can you take it before
you die I honestly don't know like I
don't know enough about it but like
truckers do it illegally or something
but like it's astronauts and snipers
actually use it and you just stay awake
wow wow yeah I don't know Serge do you
know how long you can take it before
dying uh it's not that nice to take it
doesn't have like abuse potential it
makes you feel like terrible like your
skin gets super dry so I wouldn't you
know it's not a party drug it's not like
Adderall or anything like that but uh
yeah not like not like meth um I don't
know okay I don't imagine I take that
much you'd probably die pretty quick
actually it's very strong wow good to
know yeah so what what what is it it's
like not for people who can't sleep
properly they have narcolepsy or
whatever uh yeah if you have narcolepsy
it just uh it keeps you awake during the
daytime so you don't fall asleep while
you're taking it basically um I don't
know what it does thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time